let's start with bitcoin itself uh
what's kind of your read on where we are
right now from a uh a bitcoin market
sentiment standpoint et cetera
it was pretty good doesn't it yeah we uh
yeah we had that run up to 64k i i wish
i just sold some bitcoin back then uh
but uh we dumped down 29k i feel like we
stabilized around 30k whatever whatever
uh the bear tried to do to push push us
below it we held 30k and we're up now
pretty completely comfortably at 45k i
mean how long do 100k pump what do you
reckon two months
i don't know what's your 2021
end-of-year bitcoin price prediction
115k
115k what's the logic to get us to 115k
by the end of the year
uh i i agree with dan morehead's thesis
i think uh the pantera won't have got it
wrong
and what what is their thesis
i just followed their price tracking if
you look at their price wrecking chart i
think they topped it out at 115 days uh
they've been pretty hot on that it's
worth having a lot i mean that'd be a
lot of fun
i think
all right what's going on in el salvador
you went down to el salvador uh before
the announcement you were aware of the
announcement i believe you've spent a
bunch of time with jack mullers and
strike uh you've made multiple trips to
the country what's kind of your take on
uh bitcoin acceptance in el salvador and
what that country and that leadership is
doing there
well i think we've uh had the initial
excitement of the announcement uh
that the government has made a bitcoin
legal tender but all lies on september
7th i'm going to be heading down there
late august and stay until i think
around the 10th of september and it's
all
[Music]
you know the law comes into
force on september 7th we're going to
see what the reality of this means of
people accepting bitcoin or how the
government app works
i think i think there's some nervousness
and i think there's some anxiousness
around this so i just think it's kind of
like it's kind of wait and see now right
because we don't really know how this is
going to play out
yeah and when you think about what the
bear case let's maybe start there what
do you think the bear case is for el
salvador with bitcoin and what do you
think the bowl case is
well i mean the back case for el
salvador is that the rollout is an
absolute [ __ ] show uh there's problems
with the app people don't understand it
a lot of people buy bitcoin we then go
into a bear market and by the by the
time uh bouquet's turn comes to an end a
load of people lost a load of money and
it gives the opposition a very easy
attack vector to say bitcoin was a
disaster we need to uh they campaign on
a
uh platform that we need to uh remove
bitcoin as legal tender because it's
been a disaster for the country
uh and i think there's multiple other
things that can go in there for the the
bear case i think the ball case is that
uh there's a significant amount of
investment bitcoin into the country
and uh that bitcoin finds their hand
itself into the wallets of people who
live in el salvador people start ended
up using bitcoin for remittance like uh
deal with jack balors and and it's
hugely successful for the country but
yeah one thing that i don't think works
well for none of the timing is that
bouquet uh term comes to an end when
traditionally we would be in a bear
market uh quite near the bottom of a
bear market so i think i think there's a
lot that will be dictated on price here
and and uh you know how much people
invest
yeah that makes sense and then in terms
of bitcoin beach i know you spent time
there as well explain to everyone kind
of what you saw when you went there
let me be quick uh is an evolving
project when i first went there in
december 2017 uh 2019 it was a very
early stage uh almost charitable charity
project whereby michael peterson was
giving job local kids and paying them a
bitcoin and they could spend at local
stores and it was a cute little project
where hands on the kids were getting
bitcoin and
you know they could spend it maybe at
the local purpose area or a local shop
but it was nothing that impressive it
was just another bitcoin project and
then it just kept expanding and by the
time covered ended i could travel back
to their just expanding for the whole
town and pretty much the whole of those
bitcoin eyes and everyone accepted the
bitcoin everyone knew how to use bitcoin
everyone just kind of understood it you
add to that jack malice came in a little
strike and and then the president now
launched in um
uh uh making the bitcoin legal tender in
the country so really out of the seed
that michael peterson created back two
years ago we now have a country uh
that's uh set bitcoin to be legal which
is kind of amazing really
what are you coming down
listen i want to go the two things that
are most interesting to me are one uh
how important it's going to be for the
government to actually um kind of
subsidize and and kick-start the um you
know the uh the kind of growth
trajectory of it right if they need to
be really really involved do they have
the conviction to do that could the
politicians uh be switched out through
elections etc like there's a lot of
complexity there but if we need to rely
on a government to really kind of kick
start that uh that'll be something to
watch if we don't
then it becomes really interesting where
basically the government ends up
following the will of the people and
something like a bitcoin beach serves as
a model you can actually go to other
countries and you can basically start on
a micro level you can gain some level of
adoption you can start the flywheel and
then eventually work your way up to uh
to a national government so i think
that's kind of one thing i'm watching
the second thing that's really
interesting to me is there's been tons
and tons of bitcoiners that have been
going down there uh and
it's unclear to me if people are
actually going to move there or if it's
more now hey i'm going somewhere for two
weeks let me go to el salvador let me go
check out bitcoin beach it's a one-time
trip and then i don't go back the reason
why that's interesting to me is because
if people go and either move there or
spend uh months there or go very
frequently now all of a sudden the
embracing of bitcoin becomes a huge um
you know kind of benefit or tailwind for
a government so there's a model to show
hey if you embrace bitcoin now all of a
sudden all these people are going to
come to your country from a tourism
standpoint they're going to spend more
time they're going to inject money into
your economy they're going to be able to
help you increase the jobs etc if they
only come one time and then they leave
the novelty of that would wear off
pretty quickly and you know most
bitcoiners aren't going to go to 15
different countries right so it's kind
of maybe the first second maybe third
country they get the benefit and
everyone else doesn't but that's really
the two big things that i'm watching
because i think that el salvador right
now when you have one country do it
people say that's interesting let me see
how it plays out it's if it works and
there's certain kind of milestones that
are hit or certain kind of data points
that people can show later you'll see
many more countries follow suit
yeah i think um it's quite interesting
following on twitter i've seen like
i i i think literally hundreds of
bitcoiners have now been down and
visiting
and a couple of things that are
interesting about that firstly yeah
they're bitcoin they said probably
financially in a good position so
they're spending money but also
hopefully some of them actually leave
and sat there and the idea that people
even sat there in that local economy i
think quite an important thing because
what it does is it increases the
percentage of stats which exist in el
salvador so as bitcoin continues to
increase in value it raises up the net
wealth of of the country so now i like
the idea of uh people going down there
spending their sats i like the idea of
people giving their residency which is
year three bitcoin investment i like the
idea of bitcoin companies invested in
there yeah i always think of um
bitcoin you can't it's kind of a game
really and you have a score and your
score is a the number of stats out of
the 21
million bitcoin that you own
it's the same for a country really as a
bitcoin increases in value the more
stats that country has more than raised
up the net uh net wealth of the country
so you know hopefully you're right
hopefully more people will uh be going
down the visit spending money and invest
in their bitcoin in the country hey guys
thanks so much for watching that clip of
the best business show make sure you
like and subscribe to the channel turn
on notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com so that you can get an account
we can get after it